aunque la cámara de representantes- no
está sesionando hoy muchos congresistas
demócratas están compartiendo en este
momento sus experiencias sobre lo que
fue lo que vivieron hace un año cuando
tuvieron que esconderse para evitar los
ataques de simpatizantes de donald trump
que se tomaron el capitolio que pedían
no reconocer los resultados electorales
y también pedían entre otras cosas la
cabeza pero entonces
exvicepresidente mike pence y de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi precisamente
nancy pelosi en plenaria pidió este
minuto de silencio por los cuatro
policías que perdieron su vida
defendiendo el capitolio la única
republicana que estuvo presente en estos
actos conmemorativos fue liz cheney hija
del ex vicepresidente cheney hay que
resaltar que el donald trump el ex
presidente en su comunicado dijo que
todo lo que tocaba el actual presidente
joe biden era un fracaso y que
precisamente todo este teatro que se
estaba llevando a cabo hoy era para
esconder estos fracasos el ex presidente
barack obama también
mencionó sobre la fecha la importancia
de la fecha de hoy y dijo que hoy más
que nunca en la democracia está en
riesgo en eeuu
cristóbal y también hay muchas críticas
a las redes sociales porque permitieron
expandir los mensajes infundados contra
las elecciones que rol sigue jugando
estas plataformas y cuál es su
responsabilidad en los ataques al
capitolio
un rol bastante protagónico y muy
criticado de hecho un estudio del
washington post y del medio pro pública
dice que días antes a la toma al
capitolio hace un año cerca de 10.000
mensajes en facebook se compartían
atacando la legitimidad de las
elecciones y el de la democracia
simpatizantes de donald trump hoy están
usando otros medios alternativos como
para ver como gaby y como mismo y para
transferir y compartir estos mensajes en
contra de las elecciones de la
democracia en eeuu y alegando este
fraude electoral la dejo con una frase
de una académica a la que se refirió al
respecto la académica es richard morgan
de la universidad de washington que dice
que hay una demanda en eeuu por la
desinformación y que hay medios para
suplir esta demanda